sakara is offering our listeners 20 off
their first order oh my god you have to
take advantage of this when they go to
saqara.com trash tuesday or enter code
trash tuesday at checkout that's s a k a
r a dot com slash trash tuesday for 20
off your first order all right guys i
will see you in st louis missouri the
funny bone june 3rd and 4th
houston texas june 10th through 12th
burbank california here we're going to
sell that out for sure june 18th west
nyack in new york 24th through 25th of
june then i'll be in
austin texas august 4th
through 6th springfield missouri august
9th through 20th i'm going to be in
after that pittsburgh tempe improv
caluso casino
uh kansas city missouri irvine a bunch
of other dates are on annie letterman
dot com shows this sunday i'll be in
denver at comedy works uh the 29th i
believe and then i have rescheduled
austin and dc you can get tickets at
esther on ice.com i can't wait to see
you guys and as always check out my
clothing line
sleepoverbyester.com and if you want any
of these updates to your phone text me
847-648-9098 to always be first one to
know about all this nonsense
[Music]
you guys welcome to the show it's annie
and i for maybe about five more minutes
before
before you see someone hoist themselves
a little something come and try to climb
up in their chair
[Laughter]
okay so tell me post second colonic are
you feeling a little lighter on your
feet i feel lighter on my feet i'm ready
to fight
oh
ready to knock some people out no no i
feel great i feel so good also the
hormones are out of my system i feel
like i've been exercised a demon has
come out of my body i didn't realize how
rough i was feeling until now i'm not
feeling that way
i was like i feel a little bad honestly
annie i'm not gonna lie
between
yesterday and today it looks like you've
lost 10 pounds i'm not kidding i think i
have and there's still a tart in here
it's not gone yet
i'm well also all of the egg [ __ ] that i
did and the tmj stuff i'm doing they had
me on this strict diet
so all of that was just all hormones
yeah so you were just bloated but you
actually weren't gaining weight because
you look kind of like watch me in a week
see what happens in a week i'm gonna
look you're gonna be like esther looks
fat next to her oh esther do you gain
weight you fat pig
can we just tell her that anyways when
she gets here no oh my gosh we're losing
her she's disappearing on us
she's almost just she's so petite she's
so small i don't know if i want to
release this into the world but
i did start working with a shaman a new
shaman well it's the same shaman but
we're starting to do deeper work and i
had to like boil a bunch of different
herbs and stuff
and put them in a bath
can i ask what herbs you're using just
to make there's a bunch of different
little baby
wow
so rude we have to because i have a
heart out i'm the esther of the day i
was told to come at 12 30. yeah it was
12 30
we haven't said anything too important
we did actually
what did i miss we talked [ __ ] on you
though
annie and i were contemplating because
you're so tiny and petite if we should
wouldn't
call you a fat pig well the reason we're
gonna call you a fat pig is because
i am now getting so skinny that you're
starting to look a little bigger oh my
god you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're starting to
can't be comparing i am so sorry i'm i
lost 10 pounds in one day i'm so
confused i was told 12th i'm i just want
the audience to know i'm here on time
all the time too they've always [ __ ]
it up after we literally started a
minute and a half no i just haven't i
just
annie you know that people
you talk about shamans so much i know
but here's the thing with ayahuasca
shamans this guy's not an ayahuasca
shaman he's done ayahuasca and stuff but
he doesn't promote it but my ayahuasca
shaman
they'll find you it's weird ayahuasca is
like that you can't you can't like seek
them out well you can kind of seek them
out but
you can't have mine
my boy is special
you hear that
person i mean you too could
esther i love those are they the cookman
yeah yeah they're chef pam's yes which i
don't even know what does chef pants
mean but they're so
great i i imagine they're just hard when
you put them on your [ __ ]
or your [ __ ]
what's amazing about these pants is that
carlos and i are the same size so it's
like okay if he orders one color i can
try them on and see if i want them it's
just carlos is a man it's just so weird
and i'm a very small you're the smallest
of all girls i've ever seen
oh but that you finally have what i have
with bobby yeah i mean we don't live
together we're not dating but we we are
like best friends do you guys want your
underwear
no we don't share understand then you're
not doing it right
do not share underwear with him
absolutely even though bobby did like
the smell of carlos's underwear he
really did didn't he they had a thing
wait that was real i believe that
like you're flirting with him i know is
to take back the night because
i think the affair is there
it's just not with me it's with bobby
it's just
no and then me and you oh yeah i mean if
we wanted if you if that was like
something that made sense how could this
time be so like high and tight like that
thank you sir your titties look heavy
today thank you guys they're really are
you premenstrual
possibly
uh what does that mean
oh no nothing it doesn't mean that
don't worry i was gonna say earlier is
it weird to be the same size as both
carlos and your miscarriage oh my god
i waited it out and it didn't make it
better no it the like you've been
waiting to make miscarriage jokes for a
year and now
gates
well did you see someone said that we
should make shirts that say
miss carrie and miss carry on and yeah
proceeds to like planned parentheses yes
let's do that smart
some of the proceeds some go to esther
the trash tuesday fund let's start
imagine if annie and i were making money
off your miscarriage i i i i've been
waiting for a year this has been
like dream come true are you kidding
wait now i'm like should we start a
trash tuesday charity that where we
donate to organizations that are trash
tuesday friendly but
what is it but then we also kind of get
a beach house
like all charities like someone ends up
with like a sick house
well all charities are a scam i'm like
pretty sure i think you only have to
give like what is it two or ten percent
it's like something so low well because
yeah it's like you can like create jobs
for people because then they just get
paid off of the charity money like it's
just the whole thing i don't know look
at my socks scams are those skins yes
maybe wow
i think the people the things that
people hate about us the most are that
we like kim kardashian and that we like
abortions maybe i don't know
and some people say kim kardashian is an
abortion which we would never say but it
is like it does kind of like there's
like a
one of those circle venn diagrams a venn
diagram i see the pros and cons of
having someone like kim kardashian in
the zeitgeist is that her ass
yeah are you washing it but i see the
pros and cons i feel so neutral and
neither way about her but her products
are great that's exactly how i feel i
don't like her or dislike her i don't
have i feel like
i think i was very against the
kardashians in the beginning because i'm
a little bit of a hippie even though i
like the spray tans and stuff and i
don't judge i try to judge people on
what they choose and stuff but i think
for
what i think the human experiences is to
like accept your flaws and love yourself
for who you are
and then
like they just reshaped
butts
and then stopped shaping them like that
after these girls went and got like
these giant asses now their asses are
getting smaller i'm like oh boy there's
a lot of big booty girls getting two
seats on the plane now you know that i
had to spend triple the amount to remove
my implants than what i paid for are you
what i paid eight thousand dollars for
my implants and i paid 24 000 to get
them removed that's not did you get them
in the philippines
no
you guys did you pan shells or something
like
that
repair my delilah's currency is seashell
oh that would be so sweet is that how
george pays you and you know we also
should we bring the conch shell
necklaces back are they already back
they've been back they're booker shells
they kind of came out you are a surfer
though you're like i'm not a surfer i'm
sorry you're not a sir you surf the
bottom of the ocean with a spear and you
murder fish well you know how to surf a
little bit if you don't know how to surf
you're a surfer that's by the way i've
gotten up twice still not a surfer
exactly thank you
will you do it again do you want to know
why i hate it yes and i vehemently hate
it and i'm like kind of disgusted with
people like no man that's the best hang
ten [ __ ] you
um hang yourself
um
listen okay or our friend did that so
did you think it's how we could have
been a good start for hit that big chest
don't even get me started on how hot his
body was there was a summer where all i
could think about was his athletic body
it's so sad
brody's body all i'll have is that bald
bald head oh my god the worst part of
brody brodie had a great stature yes i
will co-sign like imagine being a like a
young lady in comedy and you're
surrounded by all these like fat slobs
and then brody who's obviously so
mentally ill and unstable but it's like
i hiked with him every day and obviously
you're mentally ill
hike with you every day
i would just stare at that body and be
like i'm confused and he had the salt
and pepper and he was so fat his legs
were so long
dude so do you get that he was hot oh
brody was attractive do you yes
baseball player he's a baseball player
yeah exactly athlete i i would say
[Applause]
of all athletes yeah they have like
those leg muscles fake legs yeah they're
just
i'm getting
i'm getting straight
getting real straight straight sides
it's breaking my heart your tits are
lifting we're getting higher and higher
and higher look at that why is that
what's that split the 19.
waiting for esther to come grab those
balls i think i know why too because
they're a little bit
no i'm not there's not in a bad way a
little bit sloppier like you can be a
thick baseball yeah you don't have to be
the super ultra fit that's right they're
tall and their asses are very round yes
they're thicker well you can i don't
think they're that thick
um look at that ass
okay that's like a little that's a
tabletop
but
that looks like the kim kardashian
internet picture but you're the glass
[Laughter]
make it someone make it i it's so weird
for me to hear you be and likes have
attraction to a community because i see
i always be you as someone that views
all male comics is like so unattractive
except the hideous ones i dated
oh yeah never mind
we know is this a dangerous game to play
should we rank our top three hottest
wait wait i wanted to say i want to say
like there's this thing called chuckle
[ __ ] i don't know if people at home
know about them i think they do they're
girls that really really like to [ __ ]
comics and they will do anything to get
on those knees and suck those
microphones
and
no judgments no no we love you please
take the [ __ ] off us
i don't like to go down to the open mics
no mo
but um wait what was i going to say
about them
i don't know but you look hot today
super hot are you in the glasses like
and that side because i lost 40 pounds
getting the [ __ ] sucked out of my ass
you really do you did it i'm not
promoting it as a weight loss thing i
literally was bloated from my and the
hormones are getting on my system it's
the glasses and the eye makeup
i know isn't it cute how i started doing
my eye makeup mm-hmm i'm i'm
trying to copy you do you wanna know
what the look is yes it's called
miphoria
annie i love it
i would put crystals on but i it takes
too long well wait what were you going
to say about and to remind everyone she
doesn't have a uterus she has a
meteoritis
which sounds median but you know what
yeah i do have a medium
yeah it's a meter of an idea
um okay so there was there's a there are
some comedians
that are a little newer in the game that
are kind of they're hybrid chuckle
[ __ ] and comic like open mic
is it
and one of them is a champion of the
[ __ ] okay
she's gotten all the [ __ ] and we played
a game called pin the [ __ ] on the comic
and she would show me the dick pic and i
would try to guess which comedian it was
shut up
of the show who's the girl do we know
her she's like a suicide girl no no but
she does like you know like sex stuff
online stuff cool i love that she shared
that game but it's the funniest game in
the world but but also the top hottest
comics it's three you're free i find
none of i find them all physically
disgusting now because i kind of like
got that out of my system
um
but
i go on funny so
yeah i like i haven't thought about that
in so long i have no sense of who's hot
it's just hard to because once you play
the game you guys come on one time i
went on the road with one of my favorite
comedians who i thought i might have
like a daddy thing with and his teeth
were so dirty that i was like this is a
comic oh that's uh like cruddy like t
where it was just like oh i don't hear a
comic i don't like white things here
the
oh no it's jewish old man like white
phil alexander everyone i think if i
didn't take mine out i'd also have it
but it's no there's like a it's a saliva
a type person it really is heavily
associated for me with jewish men and
myself really yeah i'm gonna claim this
the white that your jewish man finally
i mean yeah like who's a hot
hottie i'm gonna be my three
is bobby lee one of them yes
yes yeah bobby's the best i honestly
when i first heard his voice you know
bobby is a smaller guy a short king but
his voice is really booming the way he
talks his style his energy impeccable
actually i'm like oh my god bobby's
energy is so [ __ ] hot but are you
guys into like an emir k do you like the
longest yes yeah amir
you know he's a boat guy doesn't he live
in a boat does he i think so or owns a
boat do you meer kate is very attractive
i like a fun hair vibe like a i like the
hat he also we went like a positivity
kick at the same time we kind of like
flipped our scripts and then i got in a
fight with him he was like dude you're
supposed to be positive and i was like
oh yeah i got mad we were like bumping
each other on a show one time we were
both opening in la jolla at the comedy
store together and we shared a room in
the condo and i'll never forget i i woke
up early and i was in the bed next to
him and i he looked over at me and i was
eating my luna bar and i was like
breakfast in bed and he just always
makes fun of me
that was like our sleepover moment i
love him oh i thought you were telling
us the day brody passed away that's why
he killed himself he rolled over
my second is controversial next to bobby
okay and um i just find him to be i i
have i like the brooding kind of like a
[ __ ] this life [ __ ] everyone and that's
mark mary
wait no mark honestly maybe there's a
hair situation i don't know what it is
no there's something so weird and mark
okay we love him okay lynn his dearly
departed beautiful gorgeous
absolutely amazing talented
unbelievable wonderful person just
everything we used to talk in the green
room like why is he getting like hot
he's so mad why is he getting hotter
there was this one episode he did of
course i wouldn't actually like the show
but he did it with emily um radakowski
did you see that no and they had like a
sex scene and everything and i could not
unsee that and i cannot look at marin
wait what is that i need to watch that
it's a show it was a show on netflix um
it was it was out of chicago
um oh i know i i think i know what is it
called i forget
not uh
he's definitely like a dad like a daddy
issue thing though i don't know if i see
him as the daddy though i just like yeah
i guess you're right there's no energy
of like you know what's funny is that
after i did the road with him this year
a little bit i told i was telling carlos
i'm like i think marin is like a good
expander for you because like
i just i'm like i could see you being
very marin like at 50. like i was like
trying to connect them is like a good
path harlows yes because they're both
skinny men
they're both like on their own there's
something there put in there
i just want to put i want to just give
you one of the tasks that carlos does
and i want you to imagine mark meredith
carlos goes to erawan and grabs his
bananas can you imagine marc maron
going to iran and grabbing bananas
carlos is working up towards his mirror
he like married another comic he dated a
bunch of comics like you can just see he
knows how to get like female comedians
oh can you put in the assault you the
right amount pete can you put in emily
ratakowski and mark maron good luck
spelling that it's there's a j before
the k believe it or not it's rataj and
then kowski he's definitely a male comic
that
talks to females and isn't like you know
what you know there's certain guys that
you just they don't want anything to do
with you but and he's always been like a
good advice giver one time one time i
hugged him like i hadn't seen a word he
goes you still with your boyfriend i go
yeah and he's younger than me look at
that look at that that's them
and it's so easy oh that is interesting
yeah she is a blonde on the show
that is pornographic
for me
personally
why don't i like
do it though
i don't actually have these feelings but
i can understand no no no no no no no i
want to just be
alternate reality by the way this is
like the worst if this was the reverse
and guys were talking about the hottest
which they do all the time so it's fine
do they i didn't get the google alerts
um can we uh
who else is hot those are my three oh
i'm sorry my number three is is known to
all which is jamar
[Music]
is the hottest male comic yeah
wow that doesn't even look like him
because he has hair
oh
gregory simmons is my number one
favorite guy i think he's a great guy
he's always funny
he's not a piece of [ __ ] he's a good
family guy
he's like he's just so funny and so cool
he's always fun to be around he never
takes things personally he's great amir
kaye is definitely on my list because
he's so funny he's fun he's good looking
like he's definitely on my list
number two
jamar's too like jamar jamar is a
wearing more hair pieces than me okay
have i told you guys a story about how
we did a student film together like
13 years ago and he was walking me down
the aisle and he was supposed to like
hand me off and he literally just
unscripted dipped me and gave me a big
kiss that's right and
because it's jamar we've been friends i
was just like this is hilarious i love
you
okay i that just reminded me of one of
the hottest male comics he did pass away
can you look up kevin barnett
kevin burnett is was drop dead gorgeous
and because we did a scene where we had
to make out in something you did uh-huh
[Laughter]
i didn't know him well but he was on an
episode of the episode of adam divine
party with me he's cute
[Music]
his like last picture was so weird and
epic it was so eerie how good it's like
him and mexico and the pancho yeah i was
like oh my god right
yeah who's who else is hot i don't know
look at that
i used to always make fun of because his
brother cory like works out a lot
kevin's hotter than him but i always
would be like corey's hotter than you it
would hurt him
oh i had fun with him once we we did
like we went to the comedy central there
was comedy fest in new york and we went
to the comedy central party and they
were sponsored by klondike bar so they
had all these like a refrigerator or a
freezer full of clownic bars and then me
and josh rabinowitz his friend started
just slapping every time he was about to
take a bite we slapped it out of his
hand to the point where there were none
left like we made sure every and i'm
like well now he's dead it's not as
funny but it was funny
um do we have any questions pete from
fans this week yes oh also let's start
photoshopping us babies we should get
some fun photoshops
[Music]
i am so grateful for better help yeah i
feel like we better helped our
lives yeah this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp online therapy because we all
have struggles all of us
yeah esther just getting on the chair
honestly yeah and getting off without
ants crawling all over me is hard
sometimes also we had uh we each had a
ptsd flare up on this episode did we we
did it's actually a pete tsd flare
she feels so guilty no it's fine but it
was i felt good about it and i will be
talking to my better health therapist
about it though but okay
you guys better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
and it's so much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours i
love the journal feature these past
couple weeks have been a little bit
overwhelming for all of us yeah wouldn't
you say
and that journal feature has been maxed
out by me i am writing down my thoughts
you guys yeah people ha you know
speaking of thoughts people have so many
thoughts and opinions out there about
our experiences with our bodies try
better help instead yeah every time
you're about to comment something mean
instead talk to your therapist at better
help because this podcast
is sponsored by better help and trash
tuesday listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com trash tuesday
that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p dot com slash trash
tuesday let's talk about manscaped guys
they just relaunched the ultra smooth
package it's back baby yes baby and look
guys we don't mind hair we just want you
to show us you care a little bit by
cleaning out certain areas
i know you like to think of us as
kitties but we don't want to be coughing
up hair balls
they are now bringing back your new
favorite razor so you can be set and
trimmed front to back this is the
durable yet sensitive razor that's
perfect for him and her i would actually
do back to front ester yeah say back to
front if i was you okay thank you so
much
um we are so excited to offer you guys a
discount from manscape you can get 20
off plus free shipping at manscape.com
with the code trash so like esther said
they've just relaunched an ultra smooth
package and in that ultra smooth package
is your handy lawnmower 4.0 the crop
exfoliator the crop gel and the crop
shape the crop shaver which was designed
for shaving the groin area with
confidence three precision blades
include extra wide lubricating strips
and a pivoting head for the ultimate
groin grooming
they said lubricating and pivoting head
about to slide off my chair you guys can
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code trash at manscape.com that's 20
plus free shipping with the code trash
at
manscaped.com get smooth with the
relaunched ultra smooth package from
your friends at manscapes
[Music]
hey guys this is jessica so my question
is thinking back on past relationships
was there something about an x or
something that they did that was just so
weird and bizarre but you just looked
past it because you just really wanted
that relationship to work out uh for
example i dated a guy who genuinely
thought he was a werewolf and uh we
dated for like two years so i mean i
don't know what that says about me but
yeah that's my question says you dated
marc maron
what wait that is so weird that
she was okay with him thinking he's a
werewolf i mean how narcissistic do you
have to be to think you're
aware you're like that is narcissistic
you know what else is narcissistic i and
i actually love travis barker but i
heard in an interview recently that he
was like i always knew i would be in a
plane crash and i'm like ew everyone
thinks at one point also they're going
to need the plane crash way to go like
there are people being like i was
supposed to die by 25. people remember
when trump got elected people were like
i knew he was going to get elected it's
like oh so okay but you guys realize
these are all people who probably
believe in manifestation stuff that you
love
i was gonna say if he was like talking
or walking around saying he was playing
was gonna crash but my manifestation is
not just like oh i'm making up a concept
it's more like i wanna start this
podcast so i'm gonna do it i think your
idea of manifestation is more like
intention setting yeah
that's right and then
yeah like i
but knowing something is gonna happen
that that i think kind of leans more
towards
a messiah complex where thinking you are
put on this earth to be this greater
being and it's like no you're just a
human yeah be human you're literally i
have a friend yeah i have a friend that
always he's like a little you know
cuckoo but he's always like he's like i
always imagined myself like
walking like
with all these people following me like
into the woods i was always like were
you in a hospital gown
like okay and it's also like just work
on yourself well that's how
cults start it's this self belief that
you are
you know above a certain you know a
group above us peasants you know what i
mean like
hey that is narcissism in terms of
overlooking something in a relationship
because you like the person i guess for
me this is a very me answer but when i
started dating tony hinchcliffe
he didn't have a bank account and he was
25 years old and i was like this is
insane oh i thought you were just saying
overlooking that he was tony henchl
and i took him to chase bank on sunset
boulevard and i said this man does not
have a bank account they're like do they
arrest them and i've gone to a fight
with him i'm like how is he supposed to
get a bank account if you guys won't
give him one and i like had to talk with
their ear off they were like listen
little kid because it looks so little at
that point oh my god 14 at best
screaming at them and they gave him a
bank account did they give you like a
stool or like an apple box to step on
i'll never forget that and it's funny
like yeah he had and
but i'm just i'm proud of myself that i
committed to him and i helped him get
the bank account
and look at him now way richer than you
yeah
maybe i should have like yeah his cowboy
hat costs more than your whole outfit i
believe that
um what about you annie
um i dated a rollerblader for three full
years oh that's right and he would like
but you don't understand it wasn't like
it wasn't it it got in the way of our
lives like we would like he would be
staring into playgrounds i was like you
look like a pedophile he's like no i
just wanna
i want to
slice that
the staircase or whatever i know what
the words were but i was like it was
just so
so you weren't into it when you started
it wasn't like oh it's kind of hot it
was he was like kind of good and it was
kind of but it was he would come home
like he would break his phone and come
crying he just cried a lot honestly
there was a lot of weeping and just it
was he was just a weak boy so you come
about broken up i'm like
everything click like you know how my
jaw looks like his knee would click i'm
like why does your knee have tmj did he
wear all the appropriate embarrassing
doors no
oh no cool guys don't do that um i would
by the way just want to throw this out
there it would be a really huge fantasy
of mine to rollerblade sometime i
haven't since i was little so if anyone
wants to gladly i have a pair of ruler
blades i think i bought some and i
haven't opened them yet but i would you
know what i like you guys i like the
idea of you rollerblading is literally
just pushing you you're gonna go like
this
we have to do trash tuesday excursions
oh yeah let's roller blade is there like
a roller blading ring like this i want
to learn more like there's a skating
rink i want to learn how to hold my
breath longer too yes i can take you
guys to the pool we got to teach us how
to swim um you guys i dated a really
shitty artist who thought he was a great
artist it's so bad and
he would
really really he would just had
very poor self-awareness of how shitty
he was he was hot though he was really
hot
and i couldn't really say anything wow
that's amazing
oh my god keep at it
and he wanted this career as an artist
and soon after that i was like
there's just no way to go there's
nowhere to go from here it's really hard
when you don't believe in the person
you're with like that is just not gonna
work like i've i've had little flings
with people that i was like
no i can't i don't want to be
embarrassed of you like if we're dating
i don't want to be like you have to feel
so proud and supportive
and it's not right either to feign
support like in that situation for me i
was not even being like
you know i wasn't being honest i was
like oh that's amazing that's amazing
but i didn't feel that way because i
wouldn't want that like i wouldn't want
to be with someone that didn't support
and truly believe what i'm like now i'm
like dave well
remember remembering the time you told
me that i should look into becoming a
paralegal uh
wait that's not bad advice
he said you barely walk just do it
you really do not listen i'm shifting
all of your trauma
genuinely esther i think you would have
made a great lawyer paraplegic
paraplegic
are you rolling into lawyer
imagine is a british barrister where she
has to wear the hair on top of it too
esther somebody can you guys create that
art that was a really good question that
really i had to dig deep there i know um
also okay so that same rollerblader guy
kept saying he wanted to do comedy but
he was not a funny man oh no it was like
he were you doing comedy at this time i
had a tv show on e i had like my show
everything he like he just
fancied himself and it would he would be
like i remember the joke he wanted to do
was about washing his cat i was like i
want you dead
every time you try to talk about it i
would go and i would go i'm making a
smoothie i can't hear you and i would
just push the grinder there'd be no food
in there
oh just push it i'd be like i am making
a smoothie and i felt so bad because if
he like to be a comedian you have to do
with the open mics right yeah so if
that's his dream if i'm a good
girlfriend and i want him to live his
dream but it's like this is not your
[ __ ] dream
you would be doing it every day yeah
and then so but so it was like i had to
like it was just it just hurt as an
actual professional comedian that
performed multiple times every night my
entire career sacrificed everything in
my life to do it just worked would wake
up in the morning crying blood just
screaming i want to be funnier um to
have him just be like crying i just know
i could be funnier than all these
communities like you're not you're not
[ __ ] the worst comedian you're not
funnier than the worst comedian so
annoying and honestly something i think
that comes up in our business a lot is
like people that know us see what we're
doing
and like by the way absolutely go do it
go
but i think when you've really done it
the hard real way of like open mics
three times a night for years and years
and like and then you see people trying
to just dabble you're like i don't know
how to help you you want me to help you
i don't know how yeah i'm not wearing
your [ __ ] jokes this is something
that like
you it's all up to you i mean that's why
there's one person up there on stage
like if you want help do improv right
group but like it's all on you hello
[ __ ] mamas
michael and my question is so let's
suppose each one of you has to get the
other two a tattoo what would it be and
also maybe where would you put it
love you guys and greetings from germany
oh sweetie pie
i love him i know
all right michael is still ishvikin that
means
can i use the restroom and
michael very impressive
no it means i want to [ __ ] you that was
just a joke in front of you
kiss i love you right
and michael i will [ __ ] you for safety
that's me being a jewish girl talking to
a german
soldier and that's a role play that
maybe one day will do and you can hide
her in a trunk no one will find her
um okay tattoo definitely i'm giving you
both a [ __ ] stamp okay because i
literally they're coming back and i want
one i have to be clear wait can i ask
you guys if what i have is already a
[ __ ] stamp i have i don't have a
centered tattoo on it are you gonna talk
about this semen on your back
that's it's not just that's that's
getting tattooed
that's everywhere
it hit my head
yeah let's just say your tracks were
showing
okay so i have a
it was
one that i picked off a wall when i was
16 years old in las vegas but it's not
centered it's to the right of my lower
back and it's a dragon can we see yeah
is is this a [ __ ] stamp i'm really
dragging this on she's 10 years old
bend over [ __ ] yeah
oh it's so cute oh that's so hot but
it's a trampoline
it's not a tram stamp is right in the
front it's right in the center it's kind
of like the coolest version of a [ __ ]
stab no it is like you knew that you
were like i don't want to be like
hacky so you put it to the same annie i
don't think that was my line of thinking
because i picked a picture from a wall
the wall art how old were you my first
tattoo was what but was by a man his
name is he calls himself [ __ ] joe it
was from it was in las vegas i got my
mom to sign my papers for me
um because my sister was going off to
college at unlv and i was like i went a
tattoo and she was like all right an
[ __ ] joe shout out that was 16. um
do you guys have um what are your
anxious ticks
because i'm chewing my other i pick my
nose right now yeah i pick and pull oh
that's like bobby do you like rip it
until it bleeds no dave does oh bobby
his thumb is just it's disgusting what
do we do how do we fix them it looks sad
i know it looks sickening why don't you
rub your nasty period juice all over
their fingers so they can't
well then donut oils lick it all up
um what's the next hold on let's put on
these headphones um another question oh
wait i would get esther i would get a
[ __ ] tattoo over your mouth oh my god
and i would get yeah your jizz fullback
tattoo i
always wanted a giant back piece so yes
i would actually very happily accept
that lizzie jennings actually has a jizz
tattoo wait what tattoo would you get
you have to get it for me you have to
give it to me but i in general i want to
know like i'm i'm this is a different
part i would get um
okay i would get
the tasmanian devil
um is there any world is there any world
where i get a serious tattoo where the
three of us one day
got something that like was a
little let's get 150 million dollar
spotify deal and then i'll get a
matching when we get a 150 million
dollars i will get matching tattoos for
you guys
150 million is like my name like 50
million will do matching
20 million 50 million each
esther here's what i would um the
tattoos that i dream of for you i would
get a little teardrop under your eye
and then i would get a giant kind of
like tupac across your belly or your
neck like the undertaker oh i love that
big ones right here those things would
work well on me because yes the dynamic
the big like
i would i would star on my eye starve
david
i'll get you some numbers
no because esther is hebrew for star so
maybe like a little star here
esther is hebrew for star yeah they did
it they actually named you correctly
i
i actually think amanda bynes tattoo of
her heart and her face is really cute it
is cute i agree
i thank you okay if we get rich enough i
will get a face i will get i will get a
heart matching heart tattoo with you
guys i can't do the thin eyebrows though
i don't i i think i like it wait we have
to try to do that thin eyebrow thing
that trick oh the trick the trick yeah
there's a trick to make your eyebrows
90s thin
her man's kind of cute
is he oh let's not get into this yeah
he's looking next to her this is a very
it's a dark it's a dark her honestly
amanda bynes did a true life
like one of the mtv things back in the
day where they followed her around with
her grandmother
in the it was she they went to oh dollar
stores thing amanda bynes is
was in that moment the funniest person
i've ever seen i agree i never saw that
absolutely the funniest thing i've ever
seen she was so funny she had her dog
over she was like tweaking its nipples
it was the mommy's name like she was
being so unbelievably hilarious here's
what i think that i don't know what
happened to her amanda binds genuinely
if you watch anything she's she is
[ __ ] hilarious she's a star a [ __ ]
star she's an esther
she when i used to work at equinox she
would always come in in full normal
clothes with like full makeup and i was
like that's something's going on there
that was before the public right now
right yeah this whole the whole amanda
buying story is uh
it it kind of breaks my heart a little
bit she's the perfect trash tuesday
guest i need the heart actually smaller
and closer to the yeah i agree yes yes
yes i don't want it mid-cheek like
mid-cheek but that's that you know that
was a bold choice and i i really
i love it obviously obviously done by
her boyfriend
it's done in the night
she woke up with that
sakara
you guys i can't believe we're sponsored
by them i knew you'd be excited about
sakara which is like every hot girl's
rite of passage like at least one so
close to shakira too
she's my favorite um
so sakara is nutritionally designed chef
crafted breakfast lunches and dinners
that are made with powerful plant-rich
ingredients
um
when i need a reset when i've been doing
chaos and eating fast food and all that
stuff or like or i'm in a really busy
time in my life where i need someone
else to make the meal decisions for me
that is when i hit hit up sakara i do
their plan i did this when i was
shooting alone together i had it every
single day it just made my life easy i
was able to eat foods that were healthy
that made me feel good and
taking that decision factor out oh my
god it takes up your whole day yeah and
also if this isn't just something that a
chef put together they have
nutritionists oh yeah that um help build
the menu and you guys this is
it for me at least it's not always easy
to consume all of the vegetables that
you need in a day all of the vitamins
this is this makes it so streamlined so
easy they say don't count the calories
count the colors
and with sakara you can definitely do
that you literally can't count the
colors because there's too many in the
bowl like i'm like this is like 14
colors are you being me
are you playing my role i'm the one that
has trouble counting
um but sakara is literally hot girl food
defined like this is what hot cool girls
eat and boys if you're trying to hit on
some girls fill up your fridge with
sakura oh that would be actually such a
baller move um you guys sakara is
offering our listeners 20 off their
first order oh my god you have to take
advantage of this when they go to
saqara.com trash tuesday or enter code
trash tuesday at checkout that's s a k a
r a
slash trash tuesday for 20 off your
first order it's definitely worth it for
like a reset
[Music]
hey trash queens love the show
super [ __ ] slug here
i am newly single and i'm like dating
around i'm screwing around it's great
safely
but
i'm wondering when one of the dudes i'm
seeing asks me what i'm doing on a day
that i'm with a different dude i'm
seeing
do i curve that with a lie or
do i
say i'm not doing anything do i say i
have plans with my mom
help i feel weird i know exactly
leave it on red and don't answer for two
days um
i think she's not trying to date them
why do they why do they if you're in the
middle of a date pay attention to your
date oh that is great leave it on my
leave it on red when you have time i'm
not saying game play leave it on red let
them know you saw it you're busy you're
doing other things you're not in a
committed relationship with them you
don't owe them a quick response if you
start quick responding now you owe them
a response every time i think leave it
on red let them know when you're
not chilling and not doing anything you
write them back okay that was pretty
good actually i was i was going to say
like it kind of depends on how much you
like this person
like do you wanna
be attentive and answer but i think what
you're saying is right it's very casual
it sounds like it's your life it's what
you're doing it's like up to you it's
really not their business unless they're
trying to like hang out with you right
away which i don't think plans should be
last minute like that i'm anxiously
attached so that's like a big red flag
for me
if people want to see me right now that
means
yeah i think any bad news coming up
you're both right i think you should
honor the date that you're on you don't
need to be announcing to somebody else
that you're on another date you should
just you know leave your phone down and
you can answer afterwards and check in
on the person if you like them but
you're right i mean it should be clear
that but this is you have to give
the memo that hey i am dating multiple
people and that you are honest about
that stuff like this is an exclusive
thing if you're clear on that you don't
owe him an explanation in that moment no
and in fact you don't owe him a text in
that moment if you're on another date
yeah i'm trying to think like do you say
like hanging with a friend do you say no
don't even cry because then you're just
i don't like the dangling that you're
doing things in front of people
personally i don't if that works for
other people and that's what they don't
do
i don't like because
i wouldn't want like when i was in like
a more open like casual thing with this
guy
it was like i didn't it it didn't feel
good when i knew her even though i knew
he was going places and stuff but it's
just like i don't need to like know yeah
where he is not my business
so why is he telling me yeah he's
telling me because he wants to get some
sort of like reaction and also it's like
have the most fun while you're single in
dating if this is causing like
someone asking me
where i am and me feeling possibly
obligated to give an answer already
doesn't make the dating thing fun yeah
you know what is really coming up for me
right now is that i
whenever like a friend or a dating
person whatever would ask me like where
are you what do you i i would i'm like
the first to be like i'm here and i'm
here and then i'm doing this and then
like and and i've learned now that that
gets me into trouble because then a
person who is maybe a friend me
um
but
then they grow to demand that there you
go yeah then it's like now they always
want to know and now and that's my fault
because i set that precedent that they
get to know right and so
i think your answer
yeah i'm i'm just talking about being
like healthy just for myself i would do
that because i just i know i have a
tendency to be
like and then i'm like playing games and
stuff but leave it on like let them know
you saw it like you it doesn't matter
but if i really like someone like if i
like you you're gonna know yeah like if
i'm already like even if i'm on the
other date i'm probably gonna be texting
in the bathroom like and then i'm on the
daily life but are you on the date with
the other guy because you're trying to
not have like hard feelings for this
person i'm trying i'm probably on the
date with the other guy to see what
my
options are for a future partner like
don't you wanna date around and see
what's the best match for you and
sometimes
there's just a standout person there
just always was for me though i always
would like have a guy that i was like
really into and then if they were
ignoring me i would like try to go on
dates with others but it's like i never
like wanted to be there right
but you kind of have to you owe it to
yourself to be to explore the other
option anyways
um
but yeah yeah just try to be proud so
there are no rules if you really like
someone that's i guess that's what i'll
say
if that person texting you is really
peaking your interest and you have the
you know the flutters in your belly then
yeah i would be like ugh i wanna hanging
out with someone boring like yeah what
are you doing yeah and if it's and if
it's someone like and if you're afraid
of like scaring someone off if they're
the right person for you won't scare
them off i mean esther is
clung to dave
demands day one
she moved in within moments she moved in
within minutes
i know i'm like or ugh
but if dave wasn't like your guy and you
weren't his girl he would have just been
like okay out see ya oh yeah you know
what i mean like you can't like scare
off the right person yes i think i used
to have that thing where i was like did
i come on too strong or whatever i'm
seeing another vonn's bag i'm disgusted
this is going to be i'm horrified
what's wrong with vaughn listen here's
the problem pete does have spina bifida
we do talk about this
they only have a ramp at bonds you know
what i learned i learned from my
i learned from my uh we have to start
the rumor
go fund me okay i he oh my god he's
cured
i had um i learned about bananas
yesterday oh he got us organic though
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way last week last week's episode
we were talking about soup
did anyone else get soup oh i got hot
pot i immediately went i got [ __ ] sucked
out of my ass and then i put hot pot
back in i got a hot and sour soup from
din tai fung in glendale my favorite
place
it's actually
dung
when you go there
did you know you didn't get soup i
didn't get it let's go we gotta go on a
hot pot outing there's century city mall
has a hot pot place i have been my
favorite mall waiting for a century city
mall day it's my number one favorite
place we didn't know that's where we
were going when we put it in and when
todd i was on the phone with tim dillon
there i was on the phone with tim
dillinger
we're talking juice hang on the reason
that i'm keeping half my banana here
is in the event that you've found a
disgusting food for us and i'd like to
chase it down with a banana all right uh
maybe you'll be mad at me for this one i
might not be be allowed to eat me i have
to go get for annie
oh you bastard what is it well
it's close to what you fear
i might better the only thing that's
gonna piss me off is dorian
my [ __ ] sucked out and i can't eat
oh here it is
is it because of i like
a certain animal
oh my god oh is it squid no i'm can i
leave
no
not unless the camera's on your screen
what to have delilah have that
what what is it do you like them
it's just the picture why is it already
open why are we going to be no no no i
don't want to do i don't think the
picture looks like a normal
cockroach
if you're listening it's giant water
bugs
wait i gotta see
that actually freaked me out i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
that i actually forgot what does it look
like can someone
give it to me give me the bag no i want
to show you no no no no
i'm sorry everyone i'm sorry stop please
put it away and let's just go to the
next segment
but maybe i'll get used to it no no no
stop
i you guys kind of mad i have a question
i i i didn't take a good look but annie
can you just tell me if it looks like a
cockroach
a very big one hold on i could smell the
same taste like i'll try to look at it
again i'm literally packing my things
like okay i'm gonna take a look i want
to go home i'm gonna take a little big
[Laughter]
all right
let's just can we just get back to
something like talking about rape or
the good stuff
okay
i'll eat that at some point
i can't
it's their resemblance it's their
resemblance they just were larger than i
thought they're gonna i was shocked i
was shocked i was taken by it
oh my god kalila passes away
back at the
saucy bacon episode i remember you said
what you got pete i remember you said
what you got with the snacks
bastard and i remembered that
here's what i don't know i know i did a
good job
here's how i'll eat that yeah
if you give me five minutes i come back
blindfolded
and i do not picture what i'm eating and
you just we put the 5 28 hertz in your
ears you put the binaural beats in you
put the 528 in just don't tell me what
it is i'm going to convince myself that
it is another scorpion or another insect
you brought over
if i
with that imagery in my head i can eat
that
but if i have to look at that thing and
hold on what i think is a cockroach yeah
it's the picture pass out pictures i've
left my body i'm not here i'll do it i
mean it is the size of you so it would
be upsetting thank you i no i can do it
because it's mind over matter
and
you know survivor hasn't done it in a
while but i've seen them eat some nasty
[ __ ] and
you really were born to be friends with
joe rogan yeah
you're right joe never ate the stuff but
the fact that he was around it and like
the face of it it's just you fit right
in i've watched some old episodes and i
go
i could do it
you think i like facing my fears though
i like i like the feeling the euphoria
of after you're really scared because i
am scared of that that is large okay
i have to admit like i was like a steak
but i can i
can conquer any fear i have and then i
come out feeling so much better
that's how i look at it
but it i i don't like the taste of bugs
like the bugs that we've eaten it's like
it's a stale i'm talking about you can
smell it it's just smelling so salty
stop stop stop stop i'm just like he's
like really worried about you i i am
right thank you peter are you okay but
we also live
are you okay
i'm fine i've screamed at cockroaches
many times
annie seems fine i want to get picked up
i've had to work through it yeah no but
i can do it i can do it i'm happy that
happened
i like being faced with a moment of
it's also when you scream then it just
got bigger in my head i couldn't believe
how big it was i honestly just didn't
expect i was like oh it's going to be
some little bugs well it looks like a
standard giant cockroach that's what it
looks like here's the thing what would
you would you rather eat a dried one or
a liv like a wet one if i don't even
want it
honestly annie i'm telling you right now
i don't even want to entertain what
you're saying to me because i feel like
i'm going to pass out your eyes are
different than they've ever been
it's not anger or anything it's like
help i'm going to pass out my blood
pressure has really dropped you guys do
you know she's crying
let's just change that subject look at
can we zoom down on this foot
do you know who would actually be the
perfect guest for our show that fits in
with us so well is
mia khalifa
i was just looking at her today that's
so weird she had there was this big
bustle article about like i read it i
read it her brother
and i'm like this girl
has such trash tuesday energy
she
used to do porn and now she's just like
this super cool it girl with huge tits
like
she's funny she's the tech girl she's
silly
like i think that
she needs to be on our show i think mia
khalifa is switched the [ __ ] on yep
is that a dr seuss tattoo
holy crap that's so
that's sick
is it yeah of course it is look at it
it's the hat oh the hat being tipped i
haven't read the article yet oh she's
pornhub's number one performer did she
get um
because she wore a hijab i guess and
that sent a controversy and
they she
they i think it might be the hijabis
to be honest
i've never seen tits up in my life how
was the article i haven't read it yet
but i'm excited too what is that how was
the article did you read it um it
basically just
talks about how
like her transition where it started and
yeah it's
she's a badass you know she fits in here
but now she's blocking the creeps do you
know what i like about that it's like we
are all evolving and if she wanted to
get plowed out and she thought it was
fine for you guys to like say gross
things to her back then and then she
realized she actually like through all
of this is like inspiring women and
found all these cool people that are
like positive and making her feel good
and she no longer accepts that in her
life that sort of like shitty treatment
that's awesome but i'm also just over
the idea that you have to just be one
thing your whole life yeah it's like i
know that's the easiest way to digest
who someone is because you're like well
she did porn or did this so that must be
ev you know it's like no that's just one
part of her
not the all of her she has many
different facets to her can you just
allow her to be everything she wants to
be is that okay it's also so weird when
you tell kids like i was thinking about
this yesterday it's so weird you're
bringing this up because i was thinking
about it yesterday when it's like you
tell kids like i'm not a kid stop
playing you tell children
um you tell
like people tell kids like to figure out
what they want to be when they grow up
it's like you're a million things when
you grow up you're like so many things
when you grow up i think if you believe
you can we're in the generation right
now of the rebrand anything is possible
anyone can rebrand as anything we're in
control of our social media we control
what we put out there about ourselves
like
brands look at like brands are always
redesigning their logos re you know
hiring new faces of the company like we
can all do that for ourselves and i
think mia is a perfect example i've
always thought even before mia a girl
like asa akira who is so she's one of
the funniest people i've ever met
she is just so
freaking bright and sound she posted
this one thing that brought me so much
comfort as a young girl if i think about
my young self being with boys in a
sexual way or even today how
certain men are just not they have a
very warped idea of what sex is with a
woman or how they go about it because no
one ever checked their the way they
consumed porn and porn is not real life
but coming from someone like asakira
this is what she said
if you aren't talking to your kids about
sex because it feels too awkward and
you're just hoping they are learning
about it from somewhere else don't be
shocked when their first experience is
inappropriate and devastating kids are
naturally curious about their bodies and
inherent urges they are biologically
wired this way of course they are going
to find porn just make sure they have
contacts before they do or they are
going to suffer major confusion and if
your intro to sex was me sucking 11
dicks in a warehouse that's [ __ ] up
you deserved adequate sex ed prior maybe
your parents didn't know any better and
maybe that's not their fault but we must
give kids the basic information they
need to navigate life sex is part of
that can we put a beat behind that and
make that the new sunscreen
it's so true i think it is a parent's
responsibility to say hey this is porn
and this is real life i know sometimes i
get you before your parents get to i
know sometimes you're in the closet too
young uncle jack i also am so over the
whole narrative of like once a girl
[ __ ] on camera that's all she is like
[ __ ] you that is not true
um
i've been i've been friends with brie
olsen for the last like 10 years you
know has she been openly friends with
you she
has she admitted it all right she's not
come forward yeah
um
but i think she would be another fun
person to have on the show and just talk
about all the things that she's gone
through and yeah well it's just so weird
that like
when you know as a comic when i get
pushed back for like
talking about sex on stage which by the
way literally every guy talks about
there's like two clean comics in the
world
but you know just that thing that
happened before that i mentioned you
know when that guy said that to me it's
like
when you've lived a life where guys have
only been trying to [ __ ] you all the
time like just constantly since you were
a kid like i remember getting it when i
was 12 years old like it's just like you
just get hit on all the time and then
like succumb to the pressure i fell for
blue balls so many times like like
literally pressured into [ __ ] these
guys and then to have it come turn
around and then you're like a grown-up
who i'm in a healthy relationship
totally in love
helping
[ __ ] girls feel more confident about
themselves i tell the truth i don't i'm
don't allow myself to be silenced i'm
like
doing well in an industry that people
perceive as hard i'm having a great time
i'm fun i'm filled with love i love
sharing my light i love meeting my fans
i love inspiring people and i love just
like being myself why is it now being
turned on me that i was some sort of
[ __ ] back in the day when i was had
repressed childhood
[ __ ] sexual abuse when i was
badgered to [ __ ]
badgered to [ __ ] all the time there's
something that i wanted to um it's like
what the hell what do you want go like
you're not my people don't comment on me
goodbye or if you do
it's nothing but you know what i mean
it's like now i'm a hoe yeah you begged
me to take my pants off and now i'm
alone now that i'm in love in a
monogamous relationship
spreading joint now i'm a hoe um
my one of my favorite my most favorite
quotes is because i lean in to my
sexual
escapades i have there is no shame there
is nothing you can say that will ever
ever penetrate my skin when it comes to
sex i've done it all i've sucked it all
yes and i got all of it she's right here
i love that part of me i love that part
of me now because i've obviously dealt
with my sexual trauma it wasn't always
positive but um this girl i heard it on
tik tok but she said god gives his
hardest battles to his strongest horse
i like to think of myself as one of
those strongest [ __ ] so you can
attempt all you want you are never going
to ever effectively shame
someone like me never there's nothing
you can do all right i got one more
question here
hi my name is maria i'm a sit-down
comedian from seattle 5-1 half filipino
so i might actually be the love child of
all three of you
my question for you is what frozen food
item are you i myself am leftover
spaghetti in an ice cream tub back in
the freezer
whoa so good leftover spaghetti and an
ice cream is very filipino that is
frozen food are you
i think i know what i am what well you
guys can start because i have options
okay i actually know exactly what i am
because it's the thing that i've been
eating the most for the last 15 years
it's
um amy's frozen enchiladas it comes with
one enchilada it's vegan and gluten free
a side of rice side of beans it's like
400 calories it's healthy it's simple
it's basic as [ __ ] it does the job it's
consistent that's what i want to be so
i'm a
green
chili
soup that
from
the cowgirl my old restaurant in santa
fe
the old restaurant i worked at
very seasonal a seasonal item that is
delicious but just frozen in the back
and just very warmed up and it's and i
i'm only eating out of a
uh
red coke
tumbler
from the restaurant
extra salted
i'm hungry
soup i'm a soup i have two options
um either just
a frozen banana that you
keep forgetting to use for your banana
bread
or
i swear by these i eat them all the time
they're the trader joe's thai chili
patties they're um
plant-based
they're my most favorite thing to eat i
put it underneath um my eggs in the
morning
everyone go try it okay i'm actually
rocky road ice cream let's be real it's
a rocky road
sometimes it's sweet and sometimes you
break your tooth
wait i want to eat cookies and cream ice
cream
ew not with that voice
no don't do a cookies and cream boys
cookies and cream
or cookie dough
what is your favorite give me cookie
dough cookie dough or cookies and cream
so good like literally i'm getting i'm
going places mentally just thinking and
talking about it like i need quiet time
yeah i'm in chocolate chip till death oh
that's dave's you guys have one thing in
common finally
no we both find me hilarious
we both like that one joke we laughed at
what's your ice cream do you guys know
what ube is yes yes
so but a certain brand so it's either
selecta or magnolia ube ice cream that's
what i that i just cannot i mean tubs on
tops of it i don't even put it on a bowl
in in a bowl i just eat it out of the
tub dude back in the day trader joe's
used to have a green tea gelato
that they discontinued and i couldn't
believe they were because i was buying
so much of it i was like there's no way
that this is not making money i would
eat a whole thing of it every day i used
to go to pinkberry and i would get
the green tea flavor and sit there and
eat it by myself and that was like my
main course and then i would get a
dessert flavor and like i would
pinkberry i know green tea are like it's
just a before dinner yeah that's not a
dessert
oh my gosh you guys thank you so much
for listening to this chaotic
[ __ ] show train wreck of a hit podcast
esther you always have ants coming out
of your body
and it's not me it's this it's here
because i leave home and it's here it's
not me have you ever had one crawl out
of your cookie cookies and
you are cookies and graham oh
thank you cookies and cream pie
you guys uh as always please like this
video subscribe to our channel we're
trying to get to 200k and
share it with a friend we're trying to
grow because you know what the guys in
comedy really don't like that we're here
but we're not going away so
and that is a threat
bye guys fear us
[Music]
[Music]
you